today on the matt welsh show the
governor of new york is set to fire
hundreds of health care workers for not
getting vaccinated artificially creating
a health care worker shortage and while
speaking at a church she framed her
vaccine mandates in explicitly religious
terms which is a blasphemous thing of
course but revealing also joe biden gets
his third coveted shot while announcing
that uh things aren't going to get back
to normal until 98 of all people are
jabbed with the vet with the vaccine
plus a medical journal refers to women
as bodies with vaginas and more
information has come out about the guy
who whipped up a social media mob
against the woman who allegedly said
something mean about him at a dog park
finally the local media here in my home
of virginia are not happy that i've come
to speak at the loudoun county school
board we'll play a clue a few clips of
that for you today all of that and much
more on the matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we know the left has taken over all
of the country's major institutions from
media academia the school system
government everywhere hollywood uh and
most corporations and most companies but
there are some exceptions and those
exceptions are are very special and
there's a reason why you know that's all
the more reason to support those
exceptions when we find them like
charity mobile for example charity
mobile is uh a pro-life phone company
they partner with you to automatically
support the pro-life pro-family charity
of your choice with five percent of your
monthly plan price and they have sent
millions of dollars to charities so far
they're doing real work good work in our
communities new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping when you
mention offer code walsh
and they also make it really easy to
switch you know you can keep your
existing phone number you may even be
able to keep your existing phone so
there's no reason to to uh to keep keep
your money with a with a service
provider that
frankly hates you and is opposed to you
in the culture and look there are no
contracts no termination fees and no
risk with their 30-day guarantee you get
great live customer support and great
nationwide coverage on america's most
reliable network you get all of this
while you're helping to build a culture
of life in america so switch to charity
mobile and support the causes you care
about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh you know as a humble man who
prefers to shrink from the spotlight it
pains me to have to start another show
saying i told you so but i did in fact
tell you so you may remember a few weeks
ago when andrew cuomo had finally been
pushed to resign from the governorship
and many on the right were throwing the
confetti and cheering his demise and i
said that we should slow the celebratory
parade down a little bit it is certain
that whoever replaces him will be worse
you know one thing that we ought to
understand about the left at this point
is that they never i mean never ever not
ever turn on one of their own as they
did cuomo unless
they've got a more dedicated and radical
ideologue waiting in the wings to
replace him that's the only time they do
it the media after months of hero
worship suddenly decided to hold cuomo
accountable i mean how could this be
explained was it a case of sudden onset
integrity had they seen the light were
they determined out of nowhere to be
fair objective and honest were the media
and democrats trying to oust cuomo
simply because he deserved to be ousted
no obviously not they were doing it
because they realized it would benefit
them and part of the reason why i would
benefit them is that the person who
would replace him kathy hokule
huckle
hochul i'll go with a bunch of different
pronunciations because i don't know
would be an even more reliable pawn for
the far left hocal is a particularly
dangerous type of tyrant she's a
thoroughly mediocre woman unimpressive
in every way very few accomplishments to
her name who managed to float on the
breeze into a position of power she
served one unremarkable term in congress
nearly a decade ago before losing
re-election next thing you know she's
appointed lieutenant governor and now
she's governor of one of the most
populated states in the country
these are always the types you have to
look out for much like camila harris who
made her way into politics by sleeping
with a married man and then became vice
president despite losing in the
primaries in spectacular fashion
garnering essentially zero support from
the electorate
these are these are these are the types
who along with being communists
also think they have something to prove
and kathy halcule has set out to prove
whatever it is she wants to prove
yesterday she announced that all health
care workers in the state had to be
vaccinated by midnight or be fired
listen to this
we'll be nation leading with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in a
hospital in the state of new york or
health care facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people uh who've been retired who
may have had a licensed lapse bring in
people from elsewhere that is not my
first position of my friends my my
desire is to have the people who've been
out there continue to work in their jobs
working them safely and to all the other
health care workers who are vaccinated
they also deserve to know that the
people they're working with will not get
them sick
okay so just to be clear about what's
happening here the governor of new york
is artificially engineering a hospital
staffing shortage
while at the same time claiming that
we're in the middle of a deadly pandemic
and hospitals are overwhelmed hospitals
are overwhelmed so let's uh start firing
healthcare workers by the hundreds or
thousands
this is without exaggeration one of the
most twisted and evil things we've ever
seen
she's also made it clear that there will
be no religious exemptions for any
healthcare worker who refuses a job
and she makes uh i guess this is her
legal argument for
disallowing religious exemptions and i
find it i don't know a little bit
dubious listen to this
do we have that
okay
so her legal argument for abolishing
religious exemptions is that she has
conducted a survey of the leaders of all
of the organized religions all of them
and found that all of them agree with
her
even if that were true of course i would
still would not negate religious
exemptions the opinions of religious
leaders don't supersede the first
amendment rights of individuals but
it's also not true i mean there are
something like 4 000 religions in the
world when she says that all of the
leaders of all of the religions agree
with her she means that she talked to
three episcopal priests and a rabbi
um her arguments may be laughable but
that doesn't matter as we've seen time
and again she is simply going to impose
herself
claim power and exercise it regardless
of what anybody says about it is there
any actual reason any any good reason i
mean to fire thousands of healthcare
workers the very workers who were being
celebrated as living saints only six
months ago
have these unvaccinated healthcare
workers caused any outbreaks in the
intervening months
i haven't heard about that
no one's telling us about that so if
they haven't that means they've been
working in hospitals for 18 months
without any problem
why make it a problem now
and what about those healthcare workers
who understand the science as you'd hope
they all do though you hope in vain and
haven't gotten the vaccine because
they've already been infected and they
know that natural immunity likely
provides greater protection than the
vaccine according to
uh
the studies we've seen on this
why should they get the job should they
be compelled to inject a substance into
their bodies just to what be good team
players
is that the argument
there is no response to these questions
those in power don't need to bother with
these kinds of questions at all or
responses to them they simply do what
they want to do
and inflict the punishment on anybody
who defies them this is about obedience
religious obedience
and hokio made a cl made that clear a
few days earlier while speaking at a
mega church in new york this is pretty
incredible listen to this but i prayed a
lot to god during this time
and you know what
god did answer our prayers he made the
smartest men and women the scientists
the doctors the researchers he made then
come up with a vaccine that is from god
to us
and we must say thank you god thank you
and i wear my vaccinated necklace all
the time to say i'm vaccinated
all of you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants you know this
you know who they are
i need you to be my apostles i need you
to go out and talk about it and say we
owe this to each other we love each
other
jesus taught us to love one another and
how do you show that love
but to care about each other enough to
say please get vaccinated because i love
you i want you to live i want our kids
to be safe when they're in schools i
want you to be safe when you go to a
doctor's office or to a hospital and are
treated by somebody you don't want to
get the
virus from them you're already sick or
you wouldn't be there
we have to solve this my friends
i need every one of you i need you to
let them know that this is how we can
get fight this pandemic come back to
normal and then start talking about the
real issues that we have to fighting
systemic racial injustice which exists
today and if there's a denier i will
take you on any date because i've seen
it i know it exists and we are not going
to have a blind eye to this ever again
any longer under my watch
oh she'll take you on hackle is going to
take you on
so hackle has a little bit of democrat
tourette syndrome at the end they're
shouting about systemic racism because
these people can't speak for more than
90 seconds without using the term
systemic racism but her statements
before that were revealing
she says that the vaccine is from god
except that really the vaccine is from
the pharmaceutical industry
and the mandates are from the government
it makes you wonder who god even is
according to her usage
well she clears that up quickly by
imploring the congregation to go out and
be my apostles she the governor of new
york is recruiting apostles her own
apostles not apostles of christ they're
urged to go out and find the lost sheep
and bring the sheep into the fold and
convince the sheep to stick a needle in
their arms and inject a drug into it
whether they need it or not
why well her religious framing i think
is quite appropriate this is about
religious observance obedience not to
god the real god the one true god but to
the god of the state
as far as the members of the coveted
cult are concerned the vaccine is a
sacrament getting the vaccine is a
sacramental act
at least that's how they see it
as a sign of fidelity and obedience to
the state that's why they insist that
children receive it even though their
immune system already provides them with
incredibly effective protection from the
virus
and they insist that people with natural
immunity get it
everybody else get it
whether they need it or not
because it's not about needs it's not
about health it's not about science it's
about compliance
that should be very obvious by now
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know what i was just thinking about
today uh you know i think about this a
lot how much i hate going to the auto
parts store
i just hate it fills me with rage and
that's why
i'm so grateful for rockauto.com they
just make it so much easier don't they
that walking into that auto parts store
wandering around the aisles for hours
and hours
you walk out having not you you spent
all this money on auto on auto parts you
didn't even need you didn't get the
thing you did need it's just a huge mess
that's why you need rockauto.com you
could just pull out your phone go on
your computer and you'll find the lowest
prices possible if you find it on
rockauto.com you know that that's the
best price you're going to find anywhere
you also know when you're on
rockauto.com that you're getting the
best selection anywhere you're getting
it from a family business that's been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years you go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
easy to navigate so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck and remember as
always to write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box and they know that
we sent you all right uh well if you're
watching the video as you can see we're
um in another hotel today before i move
into my new my new residence in virginia
and more on that in a little bit but
i sat down to start uh filming the show
today and the people in the control room
back in tennessee were very concerned
that my shirt matches um the furniture
here and the drapes behind there
and they wanted me to actually go change
which the problem is it takes effort
and but the other thing is that this is
i i this is something i do on purpose i
actually like to feel at sort of um
at one with my surroundings
i also like to blend in in case anybody
runs in here hoping to do me harm they
won't be able to find me because i'm
camouflaged into this is something i do
very intentionally
and uh and i have i have no issue with
it whatsoever so
all right
but i expect that
the mockery will come in the comments
and i'm fully prepared for that at this
point
uh okay let's start with this joe biden
got his third covid shot yesterday his
third one
and uh he was wearing a mask so now he's
triple vaxxed
and still wearing the mask
and he was asked while he was getting
the shot
when can we all get back to normal and
of course there's always this asterisk
every time that question is is asked
because
uh
you know i've been getting back to
normal i've been living my normal life
this entire time so when someone says
when do we get it back to normal
you know they're asking for me it's when
can i start doing the things that i've
been doing this entire time but for
those who have not been living normal
lives when can they start and joe biden
has an answer for that and here it is
total vaccinations
well i think
look
i think we get
the vast majority like just going on in
some of the
some industries it's in school
97 98
i think we're awful close and uh
but i'm not the scientist uh
i think but one thing for certain
a quarter of the country can't go
unvaccinated and let's not continue to
have a problem
98 and then we're getting close so it's
not even that 98 percent means we can
get back to normal it means we're close
at 98 and we're uh exactly 2 away
because 100 is really what he's saying
the goal is here
um
he says a quarter of the country
cannot go unvaxed
well i i'm old enough to remember when
they were telling us that 70
was the goal once you get 70
vaccinated that's the magic just like 15
days of slow the spread was the magical
uh was the magical limit then it was you
know they keep moving it and
at one point it was 70 vaccinated and
now it's 98 and even then not really and
even when we get to 100 which we never
will so i can't say win but in this in
this
magical
fantastical scenario where we get to 100
vaccination
even then
it's still not good enough because then
we got to start doing the booster shots
because apparently i mean joe biden got
his
full
dose of vaccines six months ago
and he already needs another one
so
once we get to 100 then we got to get to
200 because everybody's got to get
vaccinated again
and it will never ever end
they're basically at the point of
actually telling us that now
they're never going to come out directly
and say it will never end but that's
that's as close as they're going to come
to telling the truth on that point um
i think meanwhile
in related to this
the alberta chief health officer dina
hinshaw
in canada had some of her own thoughts
about about covid and specifically here
she's talking about she's being asked
about um outbreaks
especially outbreaks connected to kids
in school
and she's explaining what counts as an
outbreak now
and uh it's very interesting listen
so we do have that framework where
schools if they see that there are an
increased number of children who are ill
because of respiratory illness again or
teachers or staff
they can work with alberta health
services and in some ways that is
adding an additional layer of protection
because if individuals choose to not get
tested for covid but are home with an
illness
they're now counted in the list as uh
being part of that outbreak and so it's
less dependent on
needing a test to be a part of
identifying where there is an issue
we are as i mentioned working with
education to determine if there are any
adjustments that need to be made to this
framework but there are no other
settings right now aside from continuing
care and acute care as locations where
there's a significant risk of
transmission and severe outcomes if
there should be an outbreak in those
settings we are ensuring that follow-up
takes place to
mitigate and to manage outbreaks however
in schools again we are taking the
approach that an illness that fits that
definition a respiratory illness is
treated the same way whether it's
someone who's diagnosed with covet or
not and that additional measures can be
put into place
i remember when it was a conspiracy
theory
that they were pumping up the kovit
numbers by
counting a bunch of things as coveted
even if they weren't necessarily covered
i remember that when that was it was a
conspiracy you couldn't say that you
couldn't talk about that
if i had speculated about such things i
would have been kicked off a youtube and
twitter would have flagged at us
misinformation and here we have the
alberta chief health officer in canada
saying that's exactly what they're going
to do
and probably have have been doing
that if someone has coveted symptoms and
they don't test positive or even get
tested at all
and they miss school that counts as
covet
which as we went over yesterday is a
problem because literally every virus
including the common cold
has covid symptoms
if you have a if you have a migraine
and you stay home for the day that now
it's part of a coveted outbreak you had
coveted it's not coveted but it is as
far as they're concerned
so this this is what we're finding i i
think that uh the powers that be figure
at this point after 18 months
they've kind of greased the wheels
enough that they can start being
more explicit and more direct about some
of the stuff or they can come out and
actually say yeah we're counting it as
covid even if it's not
um
and uh 98 vaccination right they're
being more direct about it finally
now one more clip i want to play for you
uh not related to covet but uh jen
pisaki was
talking about the um
the spending bill 3.5 trillion dollars
now now remember it's 3.5 trillion
dollars but it doesn't actually cost
anything at all because it's going to be
paid for with taxes and what we learned
yesterday
an economic lesson it was new to me
and you know i'm sorry i didn't go to
college maybe this is one of the things
i would have learned had i gone this is
the education i missed out on that if
you pay for something
then it's free
as long as you if you pay for it up
front
then it doesn't count as
paying
which was amazing news and what they're
saying about the spending bills 3.5
trillion but they're going to pay for it
with taxes and so that means that it's
free
never mind the fact that that's actually
not true and it certainly is going to
add to deficit but uh even pretending
that it is that's that's the argument
now the question arises well you start
raising taxes you start taxing
corporations the dasterly corporations
then prices are going to go up because
they're going to pass those
costs down to the consumer
well
jen had something to say about that
listen
i want to ask you about what republicans
are pointing to in the analysis from the
joint committee on taxation they say
according to if i've read the chart
correctly
more than 16 percent of taxpayers would
see their taxes increase under the the
bill that's approved by the house ways
and means committee will the president
sign that bill
if as it is coming out of that committee
or will he insist on the changes so that
he will maintain his commitment that
taxes won't go up on people making four
hundred thousand dollars a year i have
not looked at the uh document or the
report that you have put out obviously
the president or that you have
referenced i should say that the
republicans put out uh obviously the
president's commitment remains not
raising taxes for anyone
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year there are some and i'm
not sure if this is the case in this
report who argue that in the past
companies have passed on these costs to
consumers i'm not sure if that's the
argument being made in this report
we feel that that's unfair and absurd
and the american people would not stand
for that but i will take a closer look
at this report and get you a more
substantive response
it's unfair and absurd for companies to
pass down costs to consumers that's the
way the economy works jen it's always
worked that way
and the american people not standing for
it we don't really have a choice okay
when the costs go up it's already it's
already way more expensive when you go
to the grocery store to buy basic
groceries than it was before joe biden
took office
and we're upset about it we don't like
it
but we have we we need what else are we
going to do are we all going to start
self-sustaining farms and not go to the
store anymore that would be great but
it's probably not practical so we have
to buy the stuff we don't have a choice
there are a lot of unfair things that uh
that happen in the world and we don't
have any choice but to endure them and
one of them is that the costs go up like
at any time anytime costs go up
for a company that's that supplies goods
or services to consumers
uh that means that the cost is going to
go up to the consumers as well that's
just the way that it works
because the other option is for that
company to say well you know we we could
recoup some of these costs
uh by passing it down to consumers but
you know we're going to be nice and not
do that
um it doesn't work that way it never has
it never has worked that way it's also
not unfair or or not and i don't really
think that it is unfair i think it's
pretty logical it's certainly not absurd
that's just that's that again is the way
the economy works
um
okay moving on this is from the daily
wire some more information about the guy
we started the show yesterday talking
about this guy frederick joseph who um
well i'll read from the daily wire
article and they'll set it up a little
bit it says a man who posted a short
video clip of a woman as he claimed she
made a racist comment to him as a has a
history of making accusations to his
more than 100 000 followers on twitter
his latest target her name is emma
sarley was and i was talking about the
story yesterday i didn't want to say her
name but it's now out there and it's too
late now so emma sarley was fired from
her job after she was identified as the
woman in the video and her employer was
contacted frederick joseph who took the
video and made the allegation has
written a book on anti-racism that i
mentioned yesterday called the black
friend on being a better white person he
also says on his website that he served
as a campaign surrogate for senators
elizabeth elizabeth warren and bernie
sanders big shock there
uh so
again the background here frederick
joseph was at a dog park with his
fiancee and this woman emma sarly was
there
and that's all we we really know up
until this point but there was some kind
of altercation some sort of back and
forth and uh next thing you know the
camera cuts on emmisarly is on camera
and the accusation is that she said to
frederick joseph's fiance go back to
your hood
but we we didn't know if that was
actually said we didn't know the context
behind we didn't know anything
that's what he claimed
and uh
he put her information out there her
face out there he started digging
through her life and posting all this
information put her job out her her
employer's name out there contacted the
employer himself and eventually got
her fired and was
really quite happy about it gloating
about it
not knowing anything about this woman at
all not knowing her situation
not knowing if she has
kids at home that she has to feed it
doesn't matter we're just going to take
her her job away because it makes me
feel like a big and powerful person
and you know just a quick note on that
of of power dynamics because what we're
told by the left is that well frederick
joseph is a black man emmisarly is a
white woman she's got some victim points
because she is a woman but she's got
fewer victim points than than frederick
joseph because he's a black guy so um so
she has all of the po
all of the power in that interaction
she's the one with the power
well that's interesting because
it would seem to me
that if you have the ability
to
take this unpleasant interaction you had
with some stranger
and because you're mad about it
within the space of 12 hours ruin that
stranger's life even taking her job from
her
if you have the ability to do that
whether you do it or not
it would seem like you're the one with
the power in that interaction
uh that's what power is
now
so we knew about all of that
and here's the the latest about joseph
says it should be noted that joseph has
a history of accusing white people of
racism over perceived insults big shock
there his twitter account is full of
random claims without evidence that
white women have wronged him in some way
in one tweet he took a picture of his
car and claimed a white woman approached
him while he was looking for his keys to
ask him why he was standing next to the
car
uh that didn't happen
it like i could tell you right now that
didn't happen because even if she
thought that he was what a car thief
like this is a this is a man and he's a
he's a bigger guy
some woman is going to come over to a
man who who
who she thinks is a criminal and say why
say say sir why are you committing a
crime right now
even if it was true that she jumped to
that assumption she's not going to
confront him over it
so that didn't happen
and uh
and then also in another tweet joseph
called for protesters to burn down the
kenosha police department during the
black lives matter riots
his out his allegations have caught
media attention before
in 2020 this one is this is a strange
one i actually remember this when it
happened although i didn't know the guy
behind all of this and his history but
in 2020 joseph and his family stayed at
an airbnb property and then claimed the
house was full of seemingly satanic
items and stuff for witchcraft rituals
including imagery candles books etc for
rituals and what looked like devil
worship
um
motherboard participated in a video call
with the owner of the house who walked
them through the home and pointed out
the items joseph claimed were satanic in
reality they were just art books and
kitschy objects the ritualistic markings
on the basement floor were in reality
just paint smudges
uh so this is just a bunch of stuff with
this guy pretty pretty common when you
when you stay like an airbnb's or you go
you know on vacation you stay in
someone's house they have all kinds of
just weird
kind of like because they're going for
just the general vibe they find art from
thrift stores and they put it up and
that's all it was and he claimed that
this was a where a witch lived and was
participating in witchcraft rituals and
that got media attention people parroted
that like it was
clearly true
and this guy had to go to the media and
explain himself so that's the background
on frederick joseph
and now
we finally hear from the other side of
the story
emma sarley has issued a statement
uh and before i read this statement
i'll let you i'll give you a second to
guess
what do you think do you think that
emmisarly after being targeted by this
scumbag and having her life ripped to
shreds for no reason
by this
known hoaxer
um
do you think that she's coming out and
really defending herself and
going on offense and saying how dare you
do this to me
you awful human being
you think that's what she's doing or is
she groveling what do you think
well let's find out shall we
uh sarly's complete statement obtained
by the daily wire says
in part i'm still processing everything
that's happened over the last couple
days and i thought it was important to
share what i saw and experienced
i absolutely accept responsibility for
how i could have handled things
differently in that moment on saturday
evening i watched a dog and into several
aggressive alter altercations with other
dogs in my local park and as the owners
of this dog were leaving i suggested
that they keep a handle on their dog
while visiting this particular park my
reference to back to your hood only
referred to another dog park outside the
neighborhood park i was frustrated and
upset but just to be clear i had no
intended racial undertones in my
comments whatsoever i said it because
it's an unstated rule at our local park
that when a dog is being aggressive
owners immediately remove them so it can
be calm welcoming environment for
everybody else however i fully
understand how my words come
misinterpreted
and i deeply wish i had chosen them more
carefully a brief and thoughtless moment
in my life has now led to nationwide
outrage and hurt for that i am sorry
i want to clarify that i never
threatened to call the police i never
went on a tirade as the dog owners
followed me down the street with the
phone camera on i was filled with some
panic because i'd never been in an
altercation like that and reacted in an
inappropriate way i've lived in new york
for a decade my brooklyn neighborhood
and dog park is extremely diverse
something i truly love about this city
and i never meant for my words to
contribute to pain for anyone i truly
hope we can find understanding and a
peaceful resolution to this for
everybody involved
oh emma uh
yeah there's a there's a nice peaceful
resolution for
frederick joseph
um he
rides off into the sunset he got the
attention that he wanted he got his
vengeance on you he was able to
exert this this
power over you and he got his you know
rocks off doing that um that's that's
apparently his that's his fetish it
would seem is by is embarrassing and
shaming white women he seems to really
have a thing for that in in particular
so yeah it's it's a peaceful resolution
for him
but your life is destroyed
and even more so now
because you didn't you didn't defend
yourself
yeah you didn't
you didn't say that you didn't come out
and confess to racism exactly but
you took responsibility
you took all the fault and blame on
yourself
what do you think's gonna happen
do you think the the social media mob
that a day ago was happy to ruin your
life not knowing anything about you
happy to take your job from you not
knowing i mean again they don't know if
you have kids they don't know if you
know you have some sort of
medical condition that you they need to
you need a doctor for now they've taken
your health insurance away from you too
i mean the consequences of taking
somebody's job are
are dire
doesn't mean it's that nobody should
ever lose their job but
before you set out to do that to someone
you better have a damn good reason
and there wasn't one in this case
so what do you think emma do you think
that the people that did that to you and
frederick joseph himself
you think they're going to see this
statement and say oh gee
all right i guess it was a
misunderstanding and she said she's
apologized and everything's fine i'll
call up
her employer and say you know you should
hire her back she's like she's a good
egg after all
no they're going to sit back smugly and
and cross their arms and nod their heads
and say good
yeah
i hope you learned your lesson you
deserve to have your you still but you
just still deserve to have your life
ruined
it's just it's hard it's i and then i
and then
i want to have compassion i want to feel
sorry for the emma sarli's of the world
but but i can't
i just can't find it in myself if you
won't defend yourself
then what can the rest of us do
all right from the daily wire it says
the editor of the leading medical
journey journal the landsat which
embroiled itself in controversy when it
referred to women as bodies with vaginas
on the cover of one of its september
issues apologized monday for causing
offense but chose to defend the obtuse
phrasing used in the publication uh the
the weekly medical journal called women
bodies with vaginas in an article titled
periods on display for the september
first issue the quote historically the
anatomy and physiology of bodies with
vaginas have been neglected and it was
featured on the cover
but the landsat was met with criticism
from many who argued that the journal
was itself marginalizing women by
referring to them in such a strange
manner
um
and there was some pushback against that
and that's that's reasonable pushback
there should be pushback and this is
what richard horton the editor-in-chief
this is what he said the lancet strives
for maximum maximum inclusivity of all
people in its vision for advancing
health in this instant instance we have
conveyed the impression that we have
dehumanized and marginalized women those
who read the landsat regularly will
understand that this would never have
been our intention i apologize to our
readers who are offended by the cover
quote and the use of those same words in
the review at the same time i want to
emphasize that transgender health is an
important dimension of modern health
care but one that remains neglected
trans people regularly face stigma
discrimination exclusion and poor health
often experiencing difficulties
accessing proper health care um and then
he went on so he he
allegedly apologized but then went on of
course to defend
his uh the phrasing of bodies with
vaginas he says that people have accused
us of dehumanizing women
um
that's exactly what you've done
more so than that it's it's kind of a
deep it's a de-personing
you know you're you're treating
women as if they are not whole complete
persons
but rather as you say just
bodies with vaginas
this this for
for decades right this supposedly has
been the mission of
feminism and the mission of the left
supposedly
was to was to militate against this kind
of dehumanizing objectification of women
i mean can you imagine in a different
context even just a few years ago or
even today if it was in a different
context
and someone said ah you know women
they're just bodies with vaginas
if it was some let's say some womanizing
man who was accused of being a sexist
so what does it matter they're just
bodies with vaginas that's how i'm
treating them
that would be seen as totally utterly
dehumanizing and of course that's
exactly what it is
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments
who's rocking polka dots without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
dana says i finally got the courage to
come out to my wife she just couldn't
understand it and has been really hard
on us in our marriage i hope telling my
parents about being in the sweet baby
gang goes better well i understand this
may have caused marital strife dana but
it was uh in the end it was it was worth
it
captain kangaroo says matt choosing the
second cheapest wine perfectly justifies
why his wife occasionally roasts him on
twitter uh look that's i i find that to
be the
a strategy that has not that has not
failed me because when i go in for the
wine i already know the cheapest wine is
going to be pretty bad i don't want to
spend on the more expensive stuff so i
just that's that's it's not just wine by
the way that's my approach to almost
everything in life everything certainly
everything that i buy
um obviously my clothes it's it's i just
go okay there's the cheapest level i'm
going one up so you can't accuse me of
being the cheapest i'm going i'm
classing it up just one smidge
and you know i i think it also makes you
a more content and happier person
although people would rarely accuse me
of being a content happy person but
still
when when you
because the problem is
when you have
sort of developed your tastes
in wine in like steak and whiskey and
anything
uh then your life just becomes much more
expensive so what i do is i stay away
from those top shelf things as much as
much as i can
and then i don't know what i'm missing
that's my strategy all right colin sims
says regarding the opening segment matt
didn't mention the masculine verse
feminine aspect masculine bullying is
pushing the other kid into a locker
feminine bullying
relies on character assassination
basically liberal society especially
those of the upper echelons has skewed
dramatically toward the feminine which
is why you see so much of these tactics
and cancel culture so in this case the
black guy making the cell phone video
was simply auditioning for a spot in the
mean girls click and hoping to accrue
the benefits such as
higher book sales a couple people in the
comments made that point about how
you know i was saying that bullying has
changed now because the bully
takes on sort of effects uh
powerlessness pretends to be powerless
pretends to be the offended one where i
used to be bullies were just
straightforward and they were trying to
cause offense and that's how they
uh that's how they that's how they beat
you
um
and a few people in the comments pointed
out that that in another way it was even
we i can remember back in back in my day
in high school that
this form of bullying this more
sort of this reverse psychology method
this passive aggressive method yeah
that's that's how that's how girls
bullied each other
and so it has become maybe that's a
better maybe maybe that is true instead
of uh
you know instead of bullying completely
changing it's become more feminine in a
certain way all right juliet says matt
by leaving my shopping carts all over
the supermarket parking lot i'm creating
jobs for the cart boys if we all took
care of the carts ourselves they'd all
be fired i'm a job creator
julia i've heard that excuse
a million times and that doesn't even
work anymore because a lot of these
places quite clearly
don't hire
people specifically to to return their
carts that was a job that i that i had a
long time ago is my first job in fact
as a as a working man
or i was a boy at the time
and i think i was 13 years old and
that's what i did i
was in the parking lot and i and i
collected the carts and i made sure that
parking lot was pristine a lot of these
places don't have those kind of jobs
anymore even if they do that does not
relieve you of your own social
responsibility so i don't want to hear
that and you are banned from the show
finally ryan says matt how do you
balance out the fact that you make fun
of adults who watch superhero movies and
call them childish and yet you watch
football a child's game
where men in tights jump on top of each
other some might call that pretty
childish too at least you can't deny
that it's the same kind of thing
no they're the same kind of thing
if they're not in moderation so you
could find an analog between
someone who's obsessed with an adult
who's obsessed with comic book films and
spends all their time obsessing over
cartoons and comic books
and an adult who's obsessed with sports
and spends all of their time
watching sports thinking about sports
talking about sports that's all they
care about
those are analogous
situations because those are our adults
who for them the only thing they care
about or the primary thing they care
about in life is entertainment and so
they have found their identity
in being entertained
and there are many problems with that
one of them is that it's passive you've
found a passive identity where you sit
back and
and wait for someone or something to
entertain you and that's your whole
identity so if you're doing that it
doesn't matter what the thing is it's
whether it's sports or superheroes
or or anything
um if if your if your
primary purpose in life
if if you derive meaning primarily from
being entertained from forms of
entertainment then that's a problem and
that's a recipe for an unfulfilling life
and for an adult who is not a real adult
and is not well adjusted and is not
mature and is not going to experience
the deeper joys in life
um so that's that's the comparison but
as far as superhero films versus sports
in general i think there are a lot of
a lot a lot of crucial differences i
mean for one thing sports
are a more naturally communal
uh form of entertainment you know i sit
with
my family we'll watch the game
uh you could go to a stadium and you're
with your your city you know
and you're watching the game together
now you can watch
superhero movies together but it's not
exactly the same kind of thing i mean
sports teams are tied to a city and
usually
you are a fan of that team because you
live in that city or that city at one
point you know maybe you grew up in that
city and so it ties you to your
community not in a very significant way
but it still there is that communal tie
that doesn't exist with superheroes uh
also
when you're watching professional
athletes
uh
you know there are plenty of them that
are whiny and annoying and are just in
it for the money that's true
but you're still watching people who
have dedicated their lives to being
excellent at something
and they're very very good at what
they're doing and this is the this is
the pinnacle
of all of that hard work
and so you're watching that and you're
kind of admiring the excellence
but with superhero movies
like none of these actors who are in
superhero movies this is a they're doing
it for the paycheck and nothing else
this is not a you know
they they didn't get into acting
hoping one day to put on a costume and
run around pretending to punch bad guys
this this for them is just this is a
this is a sellout thing they're doing
for the money i can't blame them
but this is not this might be these
might be excellent graphics these might
be excellent special effects
but it's not artistic excellence
as opposed to the athletic excellence of
sports
that's my rationalization off the top my
head i think it's pretty good i'm almost
convinced by it now we have a new
sponsor on the show i'm very excited
about planet fitness yeah maybe you've
heard there's an obesity epidemic in uh
in this country and and there certainly
is you know the thing is when you when
you're overweight
uh not only does that cause all kinds of
health problems but also you just don't
feel you still you don't feel right you
don't feel good about yourself that's
why you got to get to planet fitness you
can work out your stress and get back to
feeling great at planet fitness join the
judgment-free zone today for just thirty
ten dollars a month and get tons of
cardio and strength of equipment in our
clean and spacious clubs with free
fitness training and plenty of room to
move you can go at your own pace and get
back to a routine that works for you all
for just ten dollars a month don't wait
join any of our 2000 locations today in
club online or on the app see club for
details you know legacy media has
dominated the podcast world until now
our newest podcast morning wire is here
to bring you the facts to start your day
it's the only daily news podcast that
values your time and the truth and while
we're working overtime to bring you the
news you need to know we need your help
to keep it trending towards number one
so subscribe and start listening now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today is the day finally for our
rally at the loudoun county school board
in virginia we're going to be speaking
out against the radical gender ideology
of the school system and the abuse and
indoctrination of children as you know
if you've been listening over the last
several days the school board has pulled
out all the stops to prevent this from
happening
they can't do anything to stop the rally
but they can change the rules to at
least make it more difficult for some of
us to speak
during the meeting itself that's why
late last week after already shortening
the speaking time for each person to 60
seconds they announced that only
residents of loudoun county would be
allowed to address the school board it
was around the same time quite
incidentally that i decided to rent a
place in loudoun county and fulfill my
lifelong dream of becoming a virginia
resident
fortunately just by habit stance that
also means that i can still speak at the
meeting it's funny how
you know things just work out that way
in fact we flew out to virginia um where
i am a legal resident
last night and it just feels great to be
home i've mostly sort of been hanging
out in virginia today doing virginia
type stuff chilling with my fellow
virginians
getting into all kinds of virginia
shenanigans and hijinks the kinds of
things you'd have to be a virginian to
understand we're a pretty wacky bunch us
virginians
now in any case getting off the plane
was a strange experience because we
happened to emerge into the terminal to
see my own face on the tv as a fox 5 and
dc happen to be airing a report about
all this right at that moment
and i think it's worth playing the
report here so uh check it out
hey rob so we just heard from this
person on wmal this morning talking
about how he spoke out at his own board
of education meeting in tennessee well
now the same person wants to speak here
so badly tomorrow that he apparently
took out a lease in the neighborhood to
be eligible to do so
this person this is matt wall she
tweeted how do you do fellow virginians
after telling his over
672 thousand twitter followers about his
new lease in the area walsh is a
conservative blogger and podcaster who
has been more vocal about the loudoun
county school's transgender policy he's
also arguing that those with no children
in the district should be able to decide
what happens in lcps because lcps
receives federal funding and he is an
american taxpayer the london county
school board the school board speaker
change was announced late last week and
at a previous june london county schools
meeting we know tensions erupted that
meeting ended up making national
headlines speakers are now being asked
to show some sort of proof that they are
either a county a public school student
a guardian of one a county resident or a
business owner a press release sent by
the school board said that this was to
prevent quote out of town agitators who
would make board meetings a platform for
national politics or to enhance their
media profiles end quote
first of all i hate to nitpick here but
i can't help but point out that this
local news report criticizing me for not
being a local even though i'm a virginia
resident in good standing
did misspell the name of loudoun county
in their uh in their chiron as they
introduced this segment
now as a resident of loudoun county i
take exception to that i'm tired of it
personally literally every day that i've
been a resident of loudoun county
there's been a news report misspelling
the name i'm sick of it
these are the kinds of things we deal
with here in loudoun county my home
but things get worse from there because
the next chiron misgenders me twice
calling me a tennessee man nobody at fox
5 and dc contacted me to ask about my
gender if they had i would have warned
them that my gender is virginia resident
in fact they even misgendered me a third
time calling me a blogger i haven't
identified as a blogger in many years so
please stop dead naming me this is
violence the truth is that i have been a
virginian trapped in a tennessean's body
for too long and it feels good to
finally live my truth openly though i
have never though i though i have been
appalled by the bigotry i've encountered
ever since coming out as a trans
virginian
despite all of the progress we've made
there are still people who are not
prepared to accept those of us who are
state fluid those of us on the state
spectrum
this is why we have to continue to fight
for inclusion and acceptance and i will
do just that
now let's uh let's keep watching some of
this news report here it is
we did ask around about this today and i
can tell you we did get some mixed
reactions
i feel that they're taking away
voices
that they don't want people to be heard
um
and they're trying to silence
someone who doesn't agree with them i
don't against you know anybody to attend
well maybe whatever proportion is
is federally funded maybe they should be
allowed to speak to that extent i guess
just by leasing a place
so they can testify it's just not right
if you don't have a child in the county
why would you want to testify
now i was not actually able to get in
touch with walsh today and put my own
eyes on that lease i was told by schools
official that the rule change was not in
response to him wanting to participate
and they also told me that the school
system is about one percent federally
funded by the way ah the rule change was
not in response to me i believe that i
do just as my change of residence was in
response to the rule change these things
are all just happening on their own
disconnected unrelated and yet somehow
our faints our fates remained
entwined in this magical dance that we
call life
sorry if i'm getting a little bit sappy
on you there you know how we virginians
can tend to be
i also appreciated how the woman
complaining about me earlier in the clip
was wearing a mask in her car and she
had her kid wearing a mask too any
chance that i might have cared about her
opinion went out the window when she put
the mask on to drive in her own vehicle
that's one of the only advantages to
masking at this point in fact is it's a
handy cheat code letting us know ahead
of time which people we should
completely ignore
anyway in the end we're all still going
to be there this afternoon and if the
school board feels that we are intruders
and agitators and that we're making
their lives more difficult
that's good that's the point the fact
that school boards have become
battlegrounds the fact that we're even
talking about school boards at all is a
very positive development for a long
time school boards across the country
basically did whatever they want and
enacted whatever policies they preferred
and at worst there'd be like 12 people
at the meeting and maybe four of them
would express mild disapproval over it
schools and school districts were
left alone to decide what they would
teach kids decide what sort of
indoctrination they'd be subjected to we
would be out arguing about national
politics while america's future was
shaped in the schools right under our
noses it's a very encouraging sign that
we're finally redirecting our focus to
where it actually matters
and this is ultimately the reason why i
am going to loudoun county school board
to say my piece it's it's why i'll go
that's why i'll go to any school board
in the country and give my two cents
part of the reason is that yes i'm
already giving my two cents in the form
of federal tax funding i don't care if
it's one percent i don't care if it's
one penny
but much more important it's because the
school system
more than perhaps any other institution
is in the business of deciding what sort
of country we will live in what sort of
culture we will have what sort of
civilization we want we will have
and i have to live here
in this country and so do my kids even
if they won't be in the school system
themselves
that's why i get to contribute to the
conversation
and why anyone else who wants to can and
should
that's why i'll be there in loudoun
county tonight
my home so who am i canceling at the end
of all this
i guess the loudoun county school board
well that'll come later tonight and fox
5 dc
and my tennessee residents
since i'm a virginia man now
that is until i find the next school
board meeting that i want to attend
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
my sweet fellow virginians
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the governor of new york presumes to
speak for
god
cnn's chris cuomo gets accused of sexual
assault and the establishment press
tries to bury the dirt uncovered during
arizona's audit of the 2020 election
check it out on the michael nols show